hey guys before I start with today's
topic I won't announce a giveaway will
begin give a three $25 MS gift cards at
the end of the next week all you have to
do is be subscribe to our channel like
and share this video and leave a comment
about today's topic they will choose
winners randomly from the comment
section
today I'm going to talk about Johnston's
fate in the final season I'm going to
explain every vent related to John that
most certainly take place in the
upcoming season basically in this video
I'm going to introduce you with how John
story will most likely look like in the
last six episodes of Game of Thrones
Before we jump right into it let me just
highlight that none of these predictions
of mine that you're about to hear in
this video are confirmed but considering
how accurate my theories and predictions
come in so far there might be some
potential spoilers
anyways upon going to all of Westeros
that the real threat is coming for all
of them
Jon Snow is my Daenerys is heading north
to prepare for the great Ford that is
coming even sooner than they expected
they are currently sailing towards fight
Harbor the main seaport of the north
with the unsullied once they arrive over
there they will me to the track on the
Kings Road and then ride together to
Winterfell of course all of this will
take place off screen and will most
likely only see all of them together
approaching Winterfell in the very
beginning of the first episode once John
arrives in Winterfell he will have a
heartbreaking reunion with his family
with Sansa and Arya first we've been
waiting to see the union between Jon and
Arya since the very first season we had
been hoping for their reunion in season
7 but the two had missed each other
however they will finally reunite in the
first episode of the final season John
loves and cares for all his siblings by
January I have a unique bond which show
made sure to remind us of just before
the actual reunion takes place I hope he
comes back soon I remember how happy he
was to see me when he says knew his
heart will probably stop however while
there will be a few moments of a
heartbreaking reunion there will be no
time for my chatting because Winterfell
is already preparing for the war even
though Jon Snow is unaware of the fact
that the night king and his army are
marching south of the wall
brenn already informed everyone in
Winterfell as he himself through his
flocks of raymond's witness the moment
when the 19 destroy a large portion of
the wall allowing his army to march
south upon being informed about this
huge news the next scene we've all seen
Winterfell is it a soon-to-be John
having energy
meaning with majority of the northern
Lords in his OS at the Great Hall in
order to discuss their strategy and
defenses next to John most reckless is
the nearest home John presents as the
North's strongest and most trusted ally
John Alden or her mates roll kondo-san
Ravens to Lord and umber and Lady Alice
Karstark informing them that the army of
the Dead is marching south of the wall
and since their castles are the farthest
northern settlements in the north there
will be the first obstacle in the path
of the knight King this is something
John already warned the northern Lords
about in the season 7 premiere if they
breach the wall the first two castles in
their path a last hath and car whole car
stops betrayed on off anyways beside
informing Lord umber and Lady Karstark
about what's coming general Ross ordered
him to leave their castles and drive
their men to Winterfell as fast as they
can since none of them alone could stand
a chance against the army was dead at
numbers over hundred thousand White's as
well as the White Walkers and the undead
dragon once the meeting is over John
will surely ask sense about bran and she
will likely informed him that bran
spends his day in the godswood on
Winterfell beside reuniting with Sansa
and Arya John will certainly have our
union with brain as well who will at a
moment of John's arrival Ben godswood
accompanied by Sam the most important
question regarding this reunion is
veteran our brain and Samuel finally
reveal to jaha show parentage and the
answer on that question is not yet not
in the season premiere just from the to
tell John that they have something
important to tell him maester wolkan
will disrupt their conversation by
informing John that the night King
already attacked and destroyed the last
hearth and karhold seeds of the Lord and
Lady he earlier sent Ravens to but it
was too late in my opinion John will not
learn the truth about his parentage
until the third episode well in second
episode on the other hand I expect a
near story will him her pregnancy in the
season 7 finale we finally had seen the
to hook up well Brent voiceover was
explaining that they are in fact related
it's been highlighted numerous times
during this season that the nurse
believes she can no longer have children
because of a prophecy that was told to
her by miramos during the season 1
finale the prophecy tells when the Sun
rises in the West and sets in the east
when the Seas go dry and the mountains
blow in the wind like leaves when your
own quickens again and your bare living
child then he will return and not before
even though the nurse does believe in
this prophecy as Jon Snow pointed out
himself
it may not be entirely true
additionally so many people were talking
about then its ability to have children
so many seen that it seems like John and
the near scheming a baby is not even
questionable but was rather foreshadowed
Tyrion talked to Danny about her plan
for succession then he talked to John
how her dragon starred in children
she'll ever have and even Jorah thought
to John about his future child just as
John Snow stated it's highly possible
that the witch was not being honestly
Danny which along with todos foreshadows
might mean that the season finale brings
more surprises than we hoped for if
Daenerys shuli is pregnant that
definitely something John will find out
earlier in the season the only problem
with Dany getting pregnant is another
theory that has been floating around for
quite some time
if the nurse truly got pregnant because
she died in childbirth we know that her
own mother died giving birth to her
John's mother also died giving birth to
him which pulls the near simpered a
dangerous situation anyways once John
learns that he's about to become a
father the other news for harem he in
the near Sur lated as regars his father
and the nurses Reger sister brand has
been waiting for the entire past season
to reunite and talk with John and even
though he and Sam will not have a chance
to rely on the truth in their first
meeting John as well as the nearest her
cell will without a doubt learn of their
family ties at some point most probably
in the third episode many fans are
wondering how will this huge information
affect John and his relationship with
Daenerys first of all John will surely
accept the fact that he's a Targaryen
but he will always be a stark as well
which he pretty much confirmed himself
in the season 7 finale while having a
conversation with Theon John stated that
even though Theon's real father was
Balin net was more of a father to him
than Balin ever was John said you don't
need to choose your gray jr. Stark this
conversation answers itself on a
question about which house will general
present once he learns of his true
parentage now that we know how the truth
will affect John let's see how will that
same truth affect John's relationship
with Danny
then his pregnant we're all expecting
the Targaryen marriage but having in
mind that the John will almost certainly
find out about his true parentage almost
at the same time the nurse tells him
that they're about to have a baby
quite amount of fans also doubt that
this marriage will actually take place
well here's a huge surprise for you this
marriage is happening in the fifth
episode of the season I'm aware that
you're wondering how am I so sure and
this is a topic I'll make a video about
in the following days my let's just say
John has been a bastard son his entire
life and he most certainly will not
allow his child to be born out of
wedlock will witness a Targaryen burying
later in season and as a
said I'll make an entire video about
this in the following days in the second
episode of the season however John
Dean's are living north and their allies
who face a great battle against the army
of the dead this huge battle from Inter
file has been confirmed by a bunch of
leaked photos from the Winterfell set in
money glass as we can see for the final
season the production has made for the
very first time an actual battlements
sent outer walls that were in previous
seasons added in with CGI HB is also
laying down by tarps all over the place
in preparation for fake snow for all of
you that are honoring vice this a huge
news not to mention how is this
confirming a great battle for Winterfell
well let me explain to you there's not
going to be any battle scene filmed in
Winterfell said the production would not
have to bother with building extra walls
with which main characters and extras
will interact with neither would they
have to have fake snow on set unless
real people are going to march over it
long story short Jon Snow and almost the
entire living side will face hundred
thousand strong army of the Dead in
front of Winterfell the living side will
win this battle and a few more but every
single one of these battles between the
living and dead will take a lot of
casualties for both sides with the
difference being that every casualty of
the undead army will be replaced with a
casualty of the linked side all brave
soldiers that are going to sacrifice
their life on the battlefield in order
stop the night king and his army will be
erased from death and he'll increase the
numbers of the undead the army will
decrease the chance for living side to
win the greatest war after huge amount
of casualties end up on realizing that
their chance to survive the long night
is small if there will be any Jon I
realized that he has to do something
horrible in order to end the long night
and in order to save all innocent people
from the certain death Jon you have to
kill Daenerys I know you're a bit
confused about this bittersweet ending
so let's get a little bit back in the
season in the season 8 premiere that
will resurface a book about the long
night that Keeley was reading in a
previous season in the season 7 premiere
show pointed out that a book you picked
up and began reading was a book about
long night while the exact part she was
reading was about the prophecy of azor
Ahai and they did it purposely he's a
legendary figure in the fate of the Lord
of Light
thousands of years ago during the long
night as her high forged sword
Lightbringer which he used to defeat the
darkness of the great other this came at
a price however as in order to only
source two powers he had to plunge it it
in the heart of his loving wife a
prophecy that was mentioned multiple
times throughout the series foretells
that azor Ahai will be reborn as the
prince that was promised I already made
a video regarding which character might
be this prophesied Savior
by John's son of Ice and Fire seems more
and more to be the Lord's Chosen anyways
upon finding out about Joshua parentage
in season seven which basically confirms
that Johnny's A Song of Ice and Fire and
upon finding out about John's death and
resurrection in the final season it's
quite possible that Samuel proclaimed
John the prince that was promised the
hero that was reborn amid smoke and salt
a hero that will build the flaming sword
to stand against the others and if he
falls the world falls with him in the
third episode of the sixth season
already told John that he might be the
prince was promised but Samuel now at
home is John that he in fact is the
Lord's Chosen if just naturally is the
prince that was promised it means that
the nervous is probably going to die
both the John and Danny are tied to the
azor Ahai prophecy which includes a
historic legend of a hero sacrificing
his love in order to save the world from
the long night Melisandre told the nares
that she has her role to play in the
prophecy as does Jon Snow the nurses
Roland long night is most likely her
eventual sacrifice and death it seems
that just like azor Ahai who had to draw
his sword into his wife's living heart
in order to create light bringer John
will have to do the same but after the
nares gives birth to their child of
course this would mean that Jon Snow has
the prince that was promised will defeat
the night king and save Westeros but in
order to do so general had to sacrifice
the nearest havilah disappoint be his
wife and mother of their child
let me also highlight that history most
certainly matches with George RR
Martin's announced bittersweet ending
the final season in law so final reveal
who will write Ragle the dragon named
after John's father and as you probably
guessed already the third dragon rider
is Jon Snow after the heartbreaking
battle beyond the wall Daenerys only has
two dragons left and since she writes
dragon it would fit for Jon the other
last link Targaryen to write ragle into
battle at some point a few months ago I
made a video regarding the three-headed
ringer theory that already proved to be
quite accurate so basically in the
theory regular garyun statement in
Daenerys his vision the dragon has three
heads means that each of the nearest
three dragons will have their own riders
probably that are not caught up with the
books that are probably wondering when
the dragger say this let me explain it
to you
Daenerys Oh vision in the house of the
undying in both in the books and on the
show but her visions are quite different
in the books the nares so no vision of
Joginder son but she did see many other
visions so which one was the vision of
her brother Rhaegar saying the dragon
has three heads in that video I also
explained how the theory has been
as well as which characters might make
up the three-headed dragon prophecy long
story short who those three Dragon
Riders might be I said that Daenerys
obviously has an unbreakable bond with
dragon and Jon Snow being the last
Targaryen beside Danny would ride the
dragon named after his father but not
before the last season regarding the
third dragon rider that is required to
fulfill the three-headed dragon theory I
stated that it would be nice to see the
near John and Tyrion riding the dragons
into battle against the night king but I
said it was kind of too obvious and
simple to be true at least so obvious
for Game of Thrones
instead of Tyrion who seemed to have
developed connections with that dragon I
studied at the night king will be the
third Dragon Rider which came true and
therefore we would have Daenerys fired
tonight King Kai's and John snow ice and
fire riding three dragons they're heavy
guys just knows fate in the final season
mostly based on theories and predictions
of mine that are backed up with strong
evidence and proof but also based on a
very few leaked photos and as always let
me know your opinion about all of this
in the comment section down below I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
one peace